molly all and we begin with that
breaking news novak djokovic has had his
australian visa cancelled by the
country's immigration minister he now
faces deportation the world number one
tennis player will now not be able to
play in the australian open due to start
on monday we will of course bring you
much more on that throughout the morning
but let's go to our top story and there
is clearly much more pressure on boris
johnson this morning with new
allegations of two more lockdown
breaking staff parties in downing street
the daily telegraph has reported that
two leaving dues were held in april last
year
just hours before the duke of
edinburgh's funeral while the country
was in a period of national mourning one
staff member is reported to have been
sent to the shops with a suitcase to buy
alcohol another alleged to have broken
the child's swing belonging to the prime
minister's son downing street has not
denied that the parties to place our
chief political correspondent john craig
has her first report
it has been called the most poignant
photo of the pandemic
the queen mourning her beloved husband
prince philip alone at his funeral at
windsor castle during a lockdown
but the night before the mood inside
downing street was very different it's
claimed staff drank and danced into the
early hours on april the 16th last year
the eve of the duke's socially distanced
funeral the daily telegraph reports
there were two separate leaving parties
for former director of communications
james slack and one of boris johnson's
personal photographers
[Music]
the prime minister was not in downing
street that day according to number 10
having left for checkers the day before
but the latest revelations have renewed
calls for his resignation
labour's deputy leader angela rayner
tweeted the queen sat alone in mourning
like so many did at the time with
personal trauma and sacrifice to keep to
the rules in the national interest i
have no words for the culture and
behaviours at number 10 and the buck
stops with the pm
among a series of lurid allegations
about the events the telegraph claims
excessive booze was drunk after someone
was sent to the co-op on the strand with
a suitcase to be filled with bottles of
wine and that after midnight one downing
street figure went on the child's swing
belonging to wilfrid the pm's son and
broke it
downing street has not denied the
telegraph allegations and confirmed that
mr slack now deputy editor of the sun
had marked his departure with a speech
on this individual's last day he gave a
farewell speech to thank each team for
the work they'd done to support him
both those who had to be in the office
for work and on a screen for those
working from home a spokesperson said
more allegations then to add to the long
list of parties being investigated by
whitehall enforcer sue gray the
insensitive timing of this late night
drinking is likely to appall
conservative mps
and increase the pressure on the pm in
his battle for survival
john craig sky news
now we can speak now to the security
minister damian hines mr heinz very good
morning
good morning neil we have just heard uh
that took place the night before the
duke of edinburgh's funeral i'm
wondering would you on behalf of the
government wish to apologize to the
queen this morning
neil i i mean like everybody i think
who's read this story this morning like
you as well i was shocked
i was shocked to read to read it i have
only just read it it's just out in this
morning's
papers and we will have to see what
uh
what what comes out further in in in the
investigation this is a particularly
somber time of course for our
for our whole country the whole nation
shared uh
with her majesty in her morning and
as was just been said in your piece
there i think
one of the uh i mean
everybody was so struck
by that picture the the ultimate and
exceptional dignity of her majesty at
uh at prince philip's funeral and we
will have to see what we will have to
see what comes out
in the investigations this will be part
of the
uh the investigations taken on by by sue
gray and and we must wait to see what
comes through in that
sure but i mean it clearly wasn't a
somber atmosphere inside downing street
the night before again i'll reiterate
the prince philip's funeral there was a
suitcase full of booze there was music
there was dancing and
dining street has not denied any of
these details can you and i both just
accept the fact that on the face of it
what took place that night was a party
and it shouldn't have happened
so i i as i say i mean i'm shocked to
read these the these allegations and
i as you rightly say particularly at
that at that time but it is it is a
story that's just come out in the
in the press this morning i i honestly
don't
know more about it clearly i i wasn't
there and i don't know
um you know at firsthand
sorry minister but on the basis that
downing street has not challenged any of
the detail on the basis that they have
not challenged the detail of it on that
basis this was a party it shouldn't have
happened
so i look i i totally accept that
if if the details that are in this story
turn out to be true then
that would be
i mean
clearly people will people are going to
form their their judgment but
it will be part of these broader uh
investigations being undertaken by by by
sue gray the terms of reference have
been clear that those investigations
should cover
it should cover
events plural alleged events the nature
of them who attended them what the
purpose of them was
uh and and i think we we do need to see
what comes through what comes through in
that report promises also being clear
the terms of reference are clear that if
you know if if allegations are found to
be true if individuals appear to um have
been guilty of wrongdoing then action
can indeed be taken
the the line from number 10 is that the
prime minister wasn't there i'm just
wondering in what world it matters
whether or not the prime minister
attended the events the night before at
the duke of edinburgh's funeral we know
that when he has attended those events
in the past in what we have been told
repeatedly is his house his back garden
he didn't bring it to a halt so given
the fact that we know some incredibly
senior figures in downing street were at
this particular party you're certainly
not suggesting that there would have
been an event like that if any one of
them had had any doubt in their mind
about whether or not the prime minister
would have approved
so
neil i'm i'm not suggesting and and
anything i mean because look i as i said
i i don't know the detail of
or of those alleged events or or indeed
more broadly that's why we have
that's why we have the investigation uh
going on into uh you know in into the
series of of different uh allegations
and different
uh different happenings and i do think
it's important that this story has just
come out uh it's just come out this
morning i think we do need to wait to
see uh what goes on um
what comes out of that report the prime
minister made made his apology on
wednesday i think a
uh a a
a sincere and and heartfelt apology in
the context of course of the knowledge
that all of us have
of the very severe privations um that
the whole country has has had as a
result of the coronavirus restrictions
in some in some cases people being
unable to to mourn their loved ones or
to be with to be with them at the last
so these are incredibly um
important important matters and i do
think it's right
that the time is given
for for those for those investigations
to run that to run their proper course
and then if action needs to be taken
against individuals um it it can be
i i i was a minister i'll say something
this morning that i really do with
politicians i've got a degree of
sympathy for you you've been the
government minister that has been sent
out this morning having received an
absolute hospital pass yet again from
staff working inside number 10. i mean
andrew but the problem is is that all of
this raises questions about the prime
minister's suitability to be prime
minister andrew bridgen the prime
minister's position has become untenable
leadership is not just about the job
title or even making big decisions it is
equally about having a moral compass of
knowing not just right from left but
right from wrong i mean few including mr
bridgen would have expected him to be
the moral compass at the heart of the
government at the moment but he's got a
point
well i think leadership is incredibly
important and i am entirely behind the
prime minister and the government and i
think the leadership that
that the the prime minister has shown
particularly through through through the
coronavirus um has been has been very
strong we are
we've had the strongest vaccination
program in europe most tested uh
nationally in all of this we know all of
this but we're talking we're talking
about
we're talking about a party at which a
suitcase full of brews was brought in a
party at which drunkenly or otherwise
the sun the prime minister's sons swing
was broken by one of those attending
dancing drinking it was a party and all
of this the night before the duke of
edinburgh's funeral the the night before
when the queen herself will have been
busy preparing for one of the most
solemn sad days of her life she sat
alone in the charcoal i mean
these are all significant questions
about the prime minister's competence
surely
well as as you say this was a
particularly
particularly somber um moment um
and
all that you say about the
response the reaction that
people will have to to hearing this
story i totally understand i myself am
shocked to read
to read these allegations um this
morning
but i but i'm i'm just not in a position
to be able to comment
uh
further on them it's not that i'm it's
not that i'm keeping something from you
neil i mean i i don't know because i
wasn't there and and it is important
that we don't just operate off a
often news story that's not to diminish
the importance of of media which is
incredibly important but we don't work
just off one new story story stories
now
yes there have been there have been many
there have been many news stories and i
think that's i think that further
highlights why
it's important that we're able in a
deliberative democracy to have a senior
civil servant
uh somebody with a great integrity and
respect across the political
spectrum look at all of these things
in the round
uh and to and to make to make an
assessment in the round
those findings then obviously
will become public and then there'll be
an opportunity in parliament pm's
already said he will then
come and make a statement that means
then you know followed by questions and
uh and scrutiny from members of
parliament and then of course
uh scrutiny from you and and your
colleagues in the media and i think it
is important that we that that process
um
can run its course well we we await the
the findings of the investigation into
the prime minister by someone appointed
by the prime minister with great
interest i do whatever i want to dwell
just for a second on on on your briefing
the revelations yesterday they're a very
significant uh figure within the labour
party has come perilously close to what
it appears as a you know
a member of the chinese intelligence
apparatus are there any concerns in your
mind about the probity of barry gardner
no i mean neil this isn't just this
isn't a story about one british
politician or even one political party
this is a story
an incident an item
about
how
um other states can seek to
concede to influence
in our country in different ways one of
which is is political
is political interference and one of the
ways of of doing that is through
is through provision of finance and of
course that's a concern but
i mean what came out yesterday i mean
this is an example of our system working
this is our world leading intelligence
and security services
um discovering this and and finding a
way to to to to disrupt it so as i say
it's an example of a system at work
i i suppose the prime minister of course
under a huge amount of pressure this
morning he can at least console himself
with the fact that he is not prince
andrew what do you make of the decision
taken by buckingham palace to to strip
him of his military rules and indeed of
his hrh title
well these these are matters for um
for the crown matters for the palace and
i know obviously
matters in which they will
consider exceptionally exceptionally
careful now i don't think it's right for
for me to comment
damian heinz great to have you on the
program this morning really do
appreciate it
thank you
still to come on the program this
morning uh we'll be getting more
reaction to those most recent reports of
downing street parties
with one conservative mp who's already
called for boris johnson to go
and next are i'll be speaking delivers
emily thornbury about the latest
allegations of lockdown parties at
downing street also at barry gardner
and after nine i'll be speaking to the
lib dem leader sir ed davey to get his
take
on the ongoing party scan
[Music]
but let's get more on the breaking news
you've been seeing at the bottom of your
screen uh australia's immigration
minister has cancelled novak djokovic's
visa meaning he cannot defend his
australian open title
uh let's speak now to our sports
correspondent tom parmitan who joins us
on the program good to see you this
morning tom
was this expected i mean certainly
plenty of the allegations the more lurid
allegations about novak djokovic's
behavior over the past couple of months
would have led you to perhaps expect it
well certainly the polls would have
suggested that the majority of the
australian public expected them to
cancel the visa after all the back and
forth on this but it has taken the
australian government 96 hours after
that
court case that of course got so much
attention at the start of the week where
novak djokovic was backed up by the
judge who said what more could this man
have done and now we of course know that
novak djokovic has admitted to
misleading the border authorities in
australia during the filling out the
paperwork in relation to his arrival for
the australian open and we know that uh
he in all likelihood broke the serbian
covid uh rules and that is because he
tested positive on december the 16th and
didn't necessarily isolate and this is
such a mess on the eve of the australian
open they made the draw yesterday novak
djokovic was in the draw drawn against a
fellow serbian player but
we understand from melbourne that now
the decision is to kick him out and to
cancel the visa
and this is the world's number one
tennis player who has been at the center
of this saga for uh a week now and it is
one of the most extraordinary spectacles
in sport off the court of tennis because
this this has just been so
um
bitter on both sides and it's polarized
the anti-vaccination uh debates and
novak djokovic has of course said that
he didn't get a a jab because of his
covid status in december he tested
positive we've seen the pcr certificate
but it has really become much much
bigger than that and the
majority
of the australian public the polls
suggest that they want him kicked out
and the immigration minister has now
finally acted
there will though of course in this case
be another round because the novak
djokovic legal team are expected to
appeal in the courts in australia so
he's not quite on the first plane back
to serbia but
it is now the australian government who
have taken their final decision and
they've said his visas cancelled he
needs to leave australia with just a day
or two to go until the start of the
australian open
tom any thanks indeed
uh more breaking news now the latest gdp
figures for november have just been
released are man in the know our
business correspondent paul kelso good
to see you this morning paul so what are
they telling us
good morning well there's a little
glimmer of good news for the economy in
here these are the figures for november
and gdp
grew by 0.7 about 0.9 forgive me in
november but crucially for the first
time gdb has crept above that
pre-pandemic levels it's 0.7
the size of the economy above what it
was back way back in february
2019 before the
pandemic hit and that is a obviously a
significant moment it does mean we've
had nearly two years of economic decline
and the recovery
from covid and battling through kovid
has been a long one but there is a
little bit of
hope and some good news in there
services uh helped lead the
increases in november up 0.7 production
up a hair 0.1 and construction 3.5
up uh the chief economist of the office
for national statistics which manages
these numbers says the economy grew
strongly in the month before omicon
struck with architects retailers uh
couriers and accountants having a bumper
month the key word in that statement of
course is omicron these are the numbers
for november and at the very end of that
month we first heard news of the new
variant from south africa i remember
being out in the west end on black
friday that bumper
day for retailers pre-christmas at the
very end of november it was the morning
after the south african
authorities have given us details of the
new and i remember thinking surely we'll
never put all this energy this huge uh
presence of shoppers and spending and
the return of the economy that'll never
be squeezed back in the bottle of course
within days and weeks it was december it
was a desperate month for hospitality
and retail so we wait to see what the
impact of omicron is on that otherwise
good news as the economy looked at the
end of november back above pre-covered
levels
paul many thanks indeed
ah now ukraine's foreign ministry has
confirmed a massive cyber attack has hit
several government websites uh let's
speak now to our defense and security
editor deborah haynes is in care for us
this morning good to see you deborah do
we know exactly who's responsible i mean
i've got a few guesses
yes well there are there's obviously one
prime suspect that's on people's minds i
did actually ask the foreign ministry
spokesperson if anyone was suspected in
the attack and he said to me it's too
early to draw conclusions but there is a
long record of russian assaults against
ukraine and yes we woke up this morning
to find that a number of of government
websites were temporarily down in fact
the um the website of the foreign
ministry before it went down was
displaying um a warning saying that all
your information has become public and
be afraid and expect worse
clearly now there's an investigation
underway the foreign ministry
spokesperson um that i mentioned said
that um specialists are working on
restoring the i.t systems and the cyber
police are investigating what's happened
but this attack comes at a time of
extreme tension over ukraine you've had
a week of diplomacy between russia the
united states nato allies and wider
european partners about security in
europe and principally security here in
ukraine with real concerns that there is
a risk of a new a further russian
physical invasion and you'll remember
that when russia annexed crimea back in
2014
and backed an insurgency in the east of
the country there were multiple cyber
attacks against critical infrastructure
in ukraine as well as part of that
assault and
russia has always been blamed for those
attacks and one of the things that
people have been looking for as an
indication of where this this tensions
this conflict could be going is
potentially new cyber attacks and so
while we haven't had confirmation as to
who caused the cyber attacks on the
websites today uh clearly it's a a very
concerning sign at a time when tensions
are so high
certainly is deborah thank you
let's take a quick look at some of these
other headlines now and a parliamentary
report has recommended that public
funding for cricket should depend on
continuous demonstrable progress in
getting rid of racism as in gave
emotional testimony last year about the
racism he experienced at yorkshire
county cricket club mr rafiq himself
later apologized after it emerged that
he had used anti-semitic slurs on social
media in 2011.
nhs leaders are warning that it is
wishful thinking to believe the threat
from omicron is over the chief executive
of the nhs confederation said the
national data on reported cases offered
some hope
but there was still pressure on the
health service with high levels of staff
absence
well first minister mark drakeford will
today set out plans to ease covet
restrictions over the next two weeks
limits on large outdoor gatherings in
wales are likely to be the first to be
removed
a suspect in the murder inquiry into the
death of a teacher in tullamore and
county offline in ireland has been
released
irish police said the 40 year old man
was no longer suspected of killing 23
year old ashlyn murphy who was attacked
on the banks of the grand canal
the woman accusing prince andrew of
sexual assault says she will continue to
expose the truth virginia dufferin
tweeted saying that she is happy that
her case against the prince wasn't
dismissed in court
uh well ms jeffrey said this i'm pleased
with judge kaplan's ruling yesterday
that allows my case against prince
andrew to go forward
she continued i'm glad i will have the
chance to continue to expose the truth
and i'm deeply grateful to my
extraordinary legal team
their determination helps me seek
justice from those who hurt me and
so many others my goal has always been
to show that the rich and powerful are
not above the law and must be held
accountable
i do not walk this path alone but
alongside countless other survivors of
sexual abuse and trafficking
well as prince andrew prepares for a
potential civil trial over those sexual
assault allegations he has been stripped
of all his honorary military rules and
royal patronages he can no longer use
his royal highness and will no longer
perform any public duties the
announcement came from buckingham palace
which made clear the decision had been
widely discussed within the royal family
at joining us on the programme our royal
commentator aleister bruce aleister
always good to see you but i i suspect
on a morning such as this you will
you will have mixed emotions i mean just
your response to the decisions taken by
we must assume the queen in stripping
prince andrew of those military
patronages and indeed the title
the queen has been entirely resolute
here she understands that the monarchy
exists by the will of the united kingdom
and that it is expected to deliver the
highest
forms of probity and at a time
when the duke of york was facing these
charges
and after the judge had decided that
they would be answered in court
it was very sensible of the queen to
make the quick and immediate decision
that she has made
and to withdraw all those patronages and
military ranks from the duke of york
you saw no alternative to that alistair
well i don't think i did actually no i
think it was probably very helpful that
it happened so immediately
and that makes sure that the duke is
clear
to get on with defending himself
he holds very vehemently to being
innocent of the charges against him
but it would have been absolutely
impossible for this very difficult case
to proceed
while he was still taking part in royal
events
as part of the queen's family during
this diamond jubilee platinum jubilee
year
we know of course that the duke is is
proud and just they saw his own military
service and one then assumes that those
military patronages will have been very
close to his heart one wonders how how
he will be feeling having had this
decision made for him
well the duke and i and many others
served in the falklands war
and we were all military people we
served the queen we did our duty and
military people understand that the
highest standards are expected and if at
any stage your life
puts you into a situation where you
might bring
a
note of discord to the reputation of the
regiment or the organization you serve
with which is made up of a number of
soldiers sailors and men and women who
are doing their best to serve to the
highest standards then you step back
and say this is the ideal way of making
sure that the duke who has been serving
the queen in whatever way he could
is now stepped away from all military
roles and then all the civilian
charities that he has been involved with
but the queen has taken all those roles
onto herself
and will redistribute them and for the
queen then she can concentrate with the
working members of her family
in representing her responsibilities as
head of state of 15 nations
alistair just just in practical terms
how does the queen remove the the hrh
remove those patronages is there a
vellum document somewhere that needs to
be signed and sealed
no there isn't it is
the way it's done is she is the fountain
of all honor in the united kingdom
according to the constitution
and so at her will she can do that which
she wishes particularly with the royal
family but at the same time you know
there are other processes that can be
taken
and you know if there is a need to do
any more or less in the future the queen
can equally easily do that
but she is queen and these are issues
that sit within the royal prerogative
and dealing with members of the royal
family and making sure the royal family
is there to serve her role as head of
state is her principal concern she
inherited the monarchy from king george
vi in 1952 very nearly 70 years ago
and she got from him the highest
standards when he was the figurehead
during the second world war when the
united kingdom faced great difficulties
we are in great difficulties again her
commonwealth faces
all sorts of challenges through covered
in different degrees in different
nations and this is a chance in her
platinum jubilee to mark those 70 years
of service and the duke of york's case
simply had to be set to one side from
that and that is why she acted
decisively yesterday alastair always
lovely to see you thanks so much for
joining us this morning
uh just a little bit of breaking news
and this again relates to those parties
parties plural two of them of course
taking place on the same night the night
before
at the prince philip's funeral um we've
been hearing from one of those who was
involved in the party the prime
minister's former director of
communications james slack
he has said that he wants to apologize
unreservedly for the anger and hurt
caused by that party held to mark his
leaving downing street he said it should
not have happened at the time that it
did james slack able to provide an
apology this morning unfortunately the
government minister
not so
time for us to have a quick check and
see how the weather's looking
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
today brings some sunshine once the
morning fog lifts but cloud will be more
extensive over the weekend the south
will start frosty with dense freezing
fog patch he's giving some tricky
conditions but the north will be milder
central and southern england looking
most at risk of travel disruption now
the fog will slowly lift during the
morning to leave plenty of sunshine in
the south but it might linger in a few
spots across the welsh marches
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
just a reminder as to our top stories
this morning more pressure on the prime
minister with reports that two coveted
rule-breaking staff parties were held at
number 10 the night before prince
philip's funeral
[Music]
novak djokovic's australian visa is
cancelled by the country's immigration
minister the world number one now faces
deportation
will thus no longer play in the
australian open next week
new figures show gross domestic product
rose by 0.9 during november pushing
above pre-pandemic levels for the first
time
a little more on those dining street
parties now the security minister damian
hines says he's shocked about those
allegations that came to light late last
night the government minister told me
earlier he understands why people will
feel angry reading those reports
this was a particularly
particularly somber
moment um and
all that you say about the the response
the reaction that people will have to to
hearing this story i totally understand
i myself am shocked to read
to read these allegations um this
morning
but i but i'm i'm just not in a position
to be able to comment
uh
further on them it's not that i'm it's
not that i'm keeping something from you
neil i mean i i don't know because i
wasn't there and and it is important
that we don't just operate off a
of a news story
uh to try and make sense of it all let's
bring in our political correspondent rob
powell and you've almost got as
thankless a task as epir damien hines
this morning i mean we have now had an
apology of course yeah but not from
someone who is currently employed by
downing street yeah very significant
we've had a statement in the last few
minutes from james slack who used to be
the director of communications under
boris johnson worked under theresa may
um as well where he has apologized but
what's significant is that he has also
apparently in this statement confirmed
that a party did take place he said that
he apologizes unreservedly for the anger
and hurt caused by a party held to mark
his leaving downing street in april 2021
which he said should not have happened
at the time it did so that's someone on
the record that we know worked in
downing street um at the time a credible
voice that was there an eyewitness
saying that this was a party that took
place and it shouldn't have happened as
well so i think this puts this um on to
another level now
for the prime minister i think the case
for the defense will clearly be that um
he was not there number 10 saying
confirming this morning that he was at
checkers his residence on the outskirts
of london on that day
what makes it damaging though i think
are really the extraordinary details in
this telegraph story the suitcase full
of boots coming back from the co-op
which apparently had been deployed by
successive governments yeah uh an
advisor from the um coalition years says
that the suitcase had been uh a kind of
um
yeah familiar site around number 10 for
years now but the fact
of that djing on top of photocopying
machines in the basement i think when
you contrast that with what happened
hours later the queen sitting on her own
mourning her husband at his funeral i
think that is what will really anger a
lot of tory mps and a lot of members of
the public potentially even some that
until now may have been minded to cut
boris johnson some slack
give your choice awards uh thanks very
much
well the nhs has launched a new
advertising campaign to encourage 18 to
34 year olds to get their covered
booster jabs with uptake among young
people lower than other age groups uh
pleased to say
joining us now amd doctor christian
badalia he works on the front line in
the a and you might also recognize him
from his nhs session oh sorry nh
sessions djing how are you doing this
morning good to see you doctor
thank you for having me
explain why in your mind do you think
quite so few
people eligible for the booster have
actually taken up in that in that
particular age cohort of concern
so that's right less i mean just over
half the people between the ages of 18
and 30 who are eligible for their
boosters have actually taken them and
this is this number is far too low so we
have to keep encouraging them there are
a number of reasons why people aren't
taking up the the boosters or even the
the primary course of the vaccine this
could be a perceived lack of convenience
where people think it's not easy to get
a vaccine when in fact it is very easy
you can book in online nhs dot uk
forward slash covered vaccination
there's been concerns regarding side
effects where now as a doctor i can
reassure any young people watching this
that side effects tend to be very very
mild you might have a slight headache or
an achy arm and simple painkillers like
paracetamol could help and but also i
think possibly the way we are educating
people we need to make sure we get
information to young people in the right
format so
it's brilliant to see that the nhs and
government have teamed up with snapchat
on a new filter to get the information
to the right people
i will ask you a little bit more about
that in just a second doctor but just in
terms of
why young people might not have taken up
these boosters i mean in terms of
hospitalizations and serious
hospitalizations those requiring
intensive care
young people are not filling the wards
up at the moment are they
well we are seeing more young people
coming into hospital in my experience
i'm seeing more young unvaccinated
people rather than those who've been
fully vaccinated
those who are unvaccinated are eight
times more likely to be hospitalized
than those who have been fully
vaccinated and that is actually my
experience at the moment
so tell us then about the about the
campaign and this snapchat filter i am
vaguely aware of what snapchat is i
think uh colleagues in the gallery here
at sky news have often held their phone
up to put a cat's face on me in the past
but this is slightly different explain
how this is going to convince them to
get the jag
so
snapchat is a leading social media
platform used by young people when i was
growing up i do know that i was only
joking doctor right
and i'm still using snapchat myself um
and basically it's a way that people can
apply filter to photos or videos that
they they put on their um snapchat
profiles for their viewers and their
friends and their family to see so by
putting a filter that says i've been
boosted means that all their followers
can also see this and they can click the
link to booking for their own boosters
yeah honestly i'm not quite as old as i
may well appear but that's thanks to to
do lots of makeup um doctor we're gonna
have to leave it there but we do i wish
you very very well with the campaign
certainly something we want to see uh
going forward dr kishkidalia thanks for
joining us thank you thank you now it
started at 14 days then it went down to
10 then seven now
those who test positive for covid in
england can leave isolation after just
five days if that is they record two
negative lf tests on days five and six
but the decision to further ease the
rules has drawn some criticism after the
uk health security agency data released
earlier this week
found that almost a third of those with
covid remain infectious after five days
uh well let's get the thoughts that of
professor as he made the head of
imperial college london's department of
primary care and public health professor
great to have on the program this
morning um how sanguine are you about
the reduction to five days given those
uh exit tests
uh good morning i think it's a pragmatic
approach uh we have seen very high
infection rates in recent weeks which
has affected many parts of the economy
the nhs
hospitality
public transport for example teaching so
i think bringing down the
period to five days is helpful as you
mentioned it does require a negative
test on day five and day six also it's
very important that you have no symptoms
or very mild symptoms say for example if
a high temperature or a bad cough that
you should if you current isolating
either of your tests are negative so so
i think it's reasonably positive but has
to be delivered with with some caution
particularly if you have symptoms
yeah just on that part that point the
idea that so many people could still be
in a position to infect others even at
that kind of five-day point
is it guaranteed that if they are still
infectious that that would register on a
lateral flow test
well there's no guarantees probably
around 70 people
may remain infectious even with a
negative flow test after five days but
that's similar to the proportion of
being another infectious around at
around ten days which is around five or
six percent so
so by bringing it down to five days but
requiring uh two negative out of flow
tests and also improving symptoms uh
it's just similar in its effects to
having a tendency period
just in terms of of the testing itself
do you believe that we have the capacity
to make sure that this the five-day
isolation period can work
uh we will you make sure people can get
the tests so right those tests are are
then prioritized for groups that need
them such as those who are following
kind of interesting trace or key workers
there was a shortage over christmas
unfortunately but it does look like that
is now abating that may be driven by
people wanting to socialize with their
families it does seem that supply of
tests is now once again improving across
the uk
professor in your mind should the rules
be different for those who work directly
with you know for example the clinically
vulnerable
yes it might be they should be the
government has not yet clarified the
approach for nhs staff or people in care
homes but my view uh people who work
with people who are vulnerable because
the elderly or those whomever problems
should have so probably some additional
measures in place to ensure they only
affect people who may then suffer
adverse effects from an infection
uh professor azeem great to have you on
the program this morning appreciate your
time very much
there is more pressure on the prime
minister this morning after fresh
revelations about parties in downing
street a report in today's telegraph
suggests that staff held not one but two
leaving parties on the eve of prince
philip's funeral
in april of last year uh joining us now
the conservative mp sir roger gail who
has already submitted a letter of no
confidence in the prime minister sir
roger good to see you this morning um i
don't know whether you caught the story
last night or or this morning like the
government minister damian hines doing
the rounds you will have however by now
have heard about it what do you make of
what happened inside number 10 on the
eve of the queen's husband's funeral
uh
sir roger i believe you may well have
yourself on mute if you hit the button
we can try again don't worry i've got
people who do all this stuff for me so
please don't worry about it
there we go roger let's start again
shall we um good to see you again yeah
just your reaction to that which we are
learning about what happened in april
2021 i think the events that took place
on that evening were wholly unacceptable
and completely insensitive and should
never have happened
but that said i don't hold the prime
minister personally responsible for
those because patently the prime
minister was not there
but it does reveal i think a culture
within downing street
um that obviously stems from the top and
should not be permitted
do you think of course as mentioned
you've submitted your letter to the 22
committee i wonder whether the
revelations all of last night might
serve to focus the minds of certain of
your colleagues
of themselves i would doubt it because
the prime minister was not present
it is just another
event in a chapter of incidents that
should not have happened
but i do think that minds are now over
this weekend being focused
upon the need to take the necessary
action
i clearly neil don't know
and i shouldn't know
how many of my colleagues have put in
letters i'm not canvassing them i'm not
seeking support for what i have done
myself
um but i believe that there is a
momentum that is growing
yeah i mean you you must have had
communications from constituents perhaps
not necessarily related to the story the
the the individual story that came out
uh last night but about the the culture
it appears of drinking within number 10
during periods of lockdown i
is there not a real risk that the
conservative party
is going to lose vast swathes of
faithful followers simply because of
continued fealty to boris johnson
well i don't think that the image of the
downing street branch of the majestic
wine warehouse is doing us any good at
all
that that clearly has to end
but but there are it's much more
important than much more serious than
that neil
this goes back i voted against
the government on the internal markets
bill because i believe that it was quite
wrong for a british government to seek
to unilaterally break
a freely entered into international
treaty
you know there are serious political
issues about our standing in the world
that have to be addressed and i'm afraid
those issues lay straight at the
doorstep of the prime minister
given that
do we need to wait for the report of sue
gray to work out whether or not there is
any longevity to boris johnson's
political future i mean does it matter
now whether or not these events were
technically within the rules given the
public of program
i would expect that sue grey as a
responsible civil servant will produce a
holy factual report without
recommendations
she will say what has happened
and it will be up to the rest of us to
decide what then should happen
um but of course
in a sense we know because the prime
minister told us from the dispatch box
on wednesday what happened
and that's why having said i would wait
for the report from sue gray i went
public on on wednesday lunchtime after
prime minister's question time because i
believe that what was revealed was
completely unacceptable
do you believe that the metropolitan
police
should be involved in some form that
there should be an investigation perhaps
even just specifically on the events of
the eve
of the royal funeral
that's a matter entirely for the
metropolitan police it's an extremely
long time since i held a police warrant
and um my law is a bit rusty and i'm
going to try and presume to tell the met
what to do
if they feel that there is a matter if
they feel that laws have been broken
um and that it is necessary to
investigate then i'm quite sure that
they will do that the only problem with
that of course is that while we are
waiting for sue gray's report if the met
then become involved before that report
is published
that will then go on ice and it will
merely prolong the entire process
critical voices like yours have been
accused of of being in a sense that the
usual suspects nadine dora is saying
yesterday
colleagues like yourself had a track
record of not supporting the prime
minister
how fair or unfair do you think that
characterization is
um i have been described as a serial
critic of the prime minister in a sense
that's true
of my criticism my letter uh calling for
a leadership election goes back to
the barnard castle event when the prime
minister failed to take what i regarded
as appropriate decisions and action
to remove mr cummings from office
because what happened then was quite
wrong and i decided then that if the
prime minister was not capable of
exercising the right kind of judgment
then we had to have another prime
minister so yes i mean my track record
does go back a long way
but all i'd say neil is i have been
consistent
um i'm not and i've also tried to be
fair
to be fair the prime minister has
achieved some significant
uh results he's he's whether i like it
or not doesn't matter he's delivered
on brexit as he promised he was going to
after a bumpy start he's presided over
the best
world beating vaccination program that
saved thousands of lives you can't take
that away from him the problem is that
the man's judgment is flawed
um so roger i'm afraid we will have to
leave it there so roger gail good to
have you in the program this morning
appreciate it thank you
well let's just remind you as to the bit
of breaking news in the past few minutes
one of those who attended what we now
know to be parties inside downing street
on the eve of prince philip's funeral at
james slack the former director of
communications for the prime minister it
was his leaving do that night he's
issued a statement in which he says he
wants to apologize unreservedly for the
anger and the heart caused by that party
in april 2021. he said
it should not have happened at the time
that it did